what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I go over this week's
treachery debauchery and craziness
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way in let's get
started so we are going to talk about
how Andrew Tate triggered conservative
media
so Andrew Tate as you guys know has
taken the Internet by storm he literally
has been the most Googled and most viral
man on the planet for the past year year
and a half
and
I think a lot of conservative media
um
really has not
I guess been the most receptive to him
at all times because he is so
unapologetically masculine and even in
conservative media and even on the
conservative side masculinity is still
shamed so I'm gonna show you guys a clip
that went viral of Tate and why the
conservatives are misleading people
about this clip and their responses so
pull up the video
in the description Ally we decided we
wanted to talk to you after you put out
a reaction to this video about Andrew
Tate the Tucker interview and really
about conservative Embrace of Tate as a
figure uh we're gonna play a little bit
of this video and then we're gonna get
your reaction let's take a look what are
you charged with that's a really good
question I'm charged with being the head
of an organized criminal Group which is
in charge of recruiting girls to make
Tick Tock videos they face charges which
include human trafficking rape and
forming a criminal gang to sexually
exploit only fans is the best hustle in
the world are they accusing you of using
violence or no
they're accused me of using the Loverboy
method coercing them by being nice so
yeah on corporate.com I have my PhD
program and that is uh PhD is uh pimp
and hoes degree that I'm
[Music]
um
that teaches basically how I bought
girls how I met girls how I got girls to
like me how I got girls to fall in love
with me to work on webcam for me to
start to start I wanted to say this clip
is misleading and I'll tell you why
the reason it's misleading is because
the course that he was talking about
where he did have the webcam Studio was
five years ago where you notice all of
the charges are from 2022 and 2021. so
Andrew Tate did not lie because he was
talking about the charges that are being
charged at him currently not from five
years ago quote Andrew Tate is evidence
that the right can be as easily deceived
by empty platitudes and virtue signaling
is the left all the true things Tate
says about social issues are just virtue
signals to cover for his degeneracy and
I was curious you know to get your
perspective on this as a conservative
woman kind of in our media sphere and
all of that as reaction not to the
interview itself although maybe but
really Andrew Tate uh some of the
Embrace that we've seen out there
I understand the appeal of Andrew Tate
to a certain degree like if you look at
the political landscape I think a lot of
young men a lot of young single men
maybe they feel emasculated or they feel
definitely at the bottom of the
intersectional totem pole it starts by
insinuating all the guys that follow Tay
or just young single men
do you see that it's like the the
preemptive shaming and this is what
you'll notice Kevin Samuels did such a
good job of pointing this out with women
it's shame insult guilt and The Need to
Be Right represent masculinity and
strength and tell them that the problem
is progressivism the problem is feminism
you need to take responsibility you need
to strong be strong you need to work out
all of these things okay I understand
that some of the critiques that he has
as Society certainly have leftism I
would probably agree with some of the
things that he tells men to do like be
strong take responsibility whatever I
can understand uh the attractiveness of
that method or message to a lot of young
men however he is charged with
trafficking he is charged with rape he
is charged it has admitted on tape
several times that he has manipulated
young women in one video he slips up and
he says oh you know it's normal for 15
16. I mean wait uh it was the age of
consent 18 year old girls to come and
work for me and how he does it is he
gets them to fall in love with him he
promises them some kind of future
relationship some kind of long-term
commitment has sex with them and then
after that uh uses another woman to
convince this girl to then do webcam
work for him and then takes over half of
their money I cannot stand taking
accountability away from women do you
see the way talks about us it's like we
have no agency no
no oh he manipulated and coerced the
women into doing something where it's
like okay all right all right
if Margot Robbie okay okay actually now
everyone's arguing about Margot Robbie's
attractiveness right now whatever like
if some hot super hot chick that's a
nine or ten came up to the average guy
and was like I want to marry you I want
to be love you
if that girl was a bit out of what he's
normally accustomed to he might he's
gonna think there's a catch all right
like let's just call it what it is women
think a multi-millionaire
dude wants the to move them into their
Castle or whatever there's no catch and
what irritates me what makes this is so
maddening to me is that we take all of
the accountability off of the women for
making that choice and putting it on the
men and we do this by using feminist
words like coercion manipulated those
are all feminist talking points feminist
words that they put in to take
accountability off of the women
and this is my problem with the right
it's like we have no free will or agency
um I'm sorry okay your ex your boyfriend
convincing you to do cam work that is an
owl okay it's a camera ow that is a big
owl all right your boyfriend
convincing you to do cam work and then
dumping you after another that is an L
but what happened to the days where you
took the L and moved on what happened to
the days where it was like okay okay
this this wasn't now I'm just imagining
going to my father all right
and my dad's not a not a simp all right
I know a lot of you guys have simpass
dads that'll just tell you what you want
to hear all the time not my dad one time
one time
I was dating a guy my dad didn't like
right and he literally was like do you
like torture like what's wrong with you
like you know what I mean like he wasn't
the type to hold back but all these
women have these dads that just treat
them like princesses tell them what they
want to hear and then put in all these
words to take away accountability from
choices that we made and then all the
women and the men co-sign this
um I'm sorry if I went to my dad and I
said hey Dad hey all right so um this
guy I met him he wants me to move to his
castle in Romania and do cam work my dad
would say oh no no no you are not doing
that and if I went and did it anyway or
I went and I did it he would not say you
were coerced you were manipulated and
when we use these words it is feminism
because what the feminists did was they
infiltrated definitions in our language
to confuse everybody and take
accountability off of women and it's a
way that women police language they
don't like the way things sound but
reality doesn't always sound nice and
that and that is my issue where we are
now putting the women's poor decisions
on the men and it doesn't help us women
that do this are not our friends they're
absolutely not our friends because what
they do is they allow us
to live in a reality that is not true
and what I cannot stand what I I just
cannot stand for the life of me is not
allowing women to be accountable for
their decisions and blaming our choices
on the men
so I saw a tweet from Ali this week and
I'd like to say I got no personal like
beef with Ali all right I'd like to say
I don't it's funny because I A lot of
times I'll tweet at the Trad cons and I
don't know who a lot of these people are
like I'd seen Ali at a conference a
couple years ago and I liked her speech
she gave her like I think she gave a
talk or something so I gotta pick with
her no no beef I agree with a lot of
what they say but I think it's a
detriment to women
when we don't allow us to live in
reality because the more we live in
delusion the more we just start that's
how we get these crazy ladies saying
that they were just coerced manipulated
like because all the other women will
coddle them and just say oh you poor
thing you poor baby we're we're adults
it's it's like me either make the choice
or don't but don't blame the men for the
choice you made in crime manipulation
later just stop it so I see her tweet
all right so she says Andrew Tate is
evidence that the right can be easily
deceived but deceived by empty
platitudes of virtual signaling as the
left all the true things Tate says about
social issues responsibility are just as
virtue signals to cover for his
degeneracy in his own words he's a pimp
who sexually and emotionally manipulates
women into exploiting their bodies for
money I'm gonna I want to tackle this
first part one until Andrew Tate has
been charged with sleeping with an
underage chick then we cannot assume
that he is guilty of that because
there's some clip where maybe he he
mentioned something like it's like this
is so broad one we don't even know what
the age of consent is in those countries
and two until he's guilty like why are
we why like the right is against
cancel culture like it's so funny
because the right is so anti-cancel
culture yet they are still going to
crucify a man where there is no evidence
and he has not been charged at this
point he is not guilty of that crime but
yet she is talking about it like he did
it the second part I want to address is
that who are you to determine who is
moral enough
to be someone that we can look up to can
we not look up to Donald Trump because
he cheated with a corn star I know he
had he he said he didn't but like come
on guys and and this is my problem with
the right is they think they have the
right to decide who people want to look
up to and they want to police who men
look up to maybe there's a reason
outside of the campsites why men look up
to Tate I'm sorry I have done hundreds
of interviews Street interviews Tate is
the topic all the time on my show we
always cover him I have not talked to a
single man that said I started a
campsite because of Tate I have talked
to many men that said they started
working out they started cutting toxic
women out of their life I've heard many
men say they wanted to make more money
all of good things but the right if if a
guy is too unapologetically masculine
they will look for anything to crucify
that man for even though he is not
guilty at this point and it's funny
because the things that they're charging
him with are not from the campsites that
he was talking about the campsites have
been closed for five years what they're
talking about is in the last two years
it was in 2022 and this is the this is
the thing too you can never see the
context of a situation and online you're
always going to talk about things for
comedic effect like I understand this as
an Entertainer like you may make a joke
here or there and someone can take that
clip and pull you out of context but why
is the right using the same manipulation
tactics that the left is doing there and
it's because there is a attack on
masculinity from the left and the right
and you can see it because they will
always hold men accountable for doing
what they deem as toxic masculine
behaviors a man that cheats is evil he
is he is not a high value man that's
what they'll say I've literally argued
with conservatives who say a man that
cheats is not high value how crazy is
that that a man can start Charities a
man can change the entire world a man
could damn near have World Peace but if
he gives into a masculine sin then he is
not high value yet I do not see those
same people talking about how if a woman
is not a virgin on her wedding night
that she is low value I have never heard
them I have never heard them say to the
women it is your own fault for doing
this stuff it is always bailout bailout
bailout it's not your fault manipulation
coercion it's just the predatory men I
am so tired of hearing about these
predatory men I I I'm sorry if if the
bar for manipulation is getting a guy
getting you to to sell your body online
why don't we hold the women accountable
because one out of three women admits to
getting going on a date for a free meal
what those men were coerced into giving
them food and I know you might say it's
not the same it's not the same but my
point is that there is a double standard
Whenever there is a toxically masculine
sin the conservative demon as so much
more evil than all other sins the same
Christians will say that they don't have
the right that all that all sin is the
same but it's like who are you to
determine what sin we crucify someone
off of I mean Paul was a murderer
so
what the right will do is if there is a
toxically masculine sin they will never
let the media personality live it down
and the funny thing is if we dug into a
lot of conservatives pasts
what percent of the conservative women
were virgins on their wedding days what
percent of the conservative women
married young what percent actually did
the quote-unquote Trad con thing but we
never crucify those women we'll let Born
Again Hoes Be preachers like this is the
craziness we will have women that sold
sex that sold sex that they will not
crucify at the same level of Andrew Tate
who himself said that he has never paid
for sex now I I under my point is not
about the sex work okay my point is not
that sex work is good I I'm not a fan of
sex work I I borderline sometimes think
we should ban porn altogether okay but
my point is the way the right reacts to
masculine sin is completely different
than the way the right reacts to
feminine sin now what was Tate talking
about when he was talking about being a
pimp all right let's pull the club if
you could have scared a girl and put her
on the street she's just gonna walk off
and leave you're never gonna see her
again
she has to respect you and love you and
want to work with you and that's done
through positive
pimp positively inspirational motivating
person it's third positive energy
there's no negative energy in this
business you have to be policy my
question is this the evil guy that
they're
to be
is this the evil does this sound like
the story that they're telling why does
the right have Matrix agents like my
question is who called all of them who
who sent the call I don't know it
doesn't make sense but like let's go
back to the the alley tweet I don't know
if he's guilty of the Romanian charges
but despite the moral rot he represents
I hope the justice prevails in his favor
if the allegations against him are not
proven but beyond that he's not worth
defending he says some true things but
he's just as far from real truth as
goodness as men as any miscreant on the
left the monologue the montages and the
Montage I hate people that use big words
for no reason the montages enlightening
look so my question is who are you to
decide
who is moral enough who is the perfect
amount of moral enough if the guy hasn't
done campsites in five years that's
that's half a decade ago why are you why
do you think you are the Arbiter of
moral enough and do you apply the same
standard to Donald Trump who cheated on
his wife
is he no longer moral enough to look up
to like this [__] is so stupid so I
respond okay
and I think I thought I gave a pleasant
nice response I said oh come on Ali
sexually and I'm gonna tell you guys
what I mean like this oh come on Ali
sexually and emotionally manipulates
woman I quoted that is feminist speak we
don't need this on the right you know
damn well there's nothing a man could
say to a woman like you or me to do this
type of stuff these women made their own
choices stop blaming the men now did I
personally attack her no
but I will call out feminist language we
need to stop using their language the
feminists have come into our legal
system in the last hundred years to
change the definitions of things coerced
manipulated narcissist all of those
words are the feminist infiltrating the
system and using these words to
weaponize men and we need to stop doing
it
and this is why it's it's frustrating to
a lot of men because the same shaming
tactics that we see on the left or on
the right and the other thing is I find
it insulting that you somehow bail women
out of our decisions to do things it is
insulting to women like me who would
never do cam work it is insulting to why
the great wives and mothers to blame a
woman's decision to do cam work on a man
and especially to back that up in any
sense legally I think it is wrong and I
think it is disgusting women make their
beds they gotta lie in it and the only
way that women will be helped in the
long term is if the legal system stops
bailing women out of our bad decisions
if the conservatives stop bailing women
out of our bad decisions if the simps
stop bailing women out of our bad
decisions because
we are constantly coddled and it's not
helping us because we think we can do
whatever we want and get away with it
when the truth is there are real life
consequences for these decisions and it
does not help us to say oh she was
coerced and manipulated no she made a
choice
this was the worst part
Pearl pleasure interacting with you are
you sensing sarcasm here are are you
guys sensing sarcasm I don't know I'm
sending some sarcasm I was having a
jolly old time but now pleasure
interacting with you all right why do
you use so many exclamations I have been
curious about this so I thought I'd ask
I don't know if it's a tick you're truly
yelling or it's some kind of irony
think they add a little spice to the
tweets I think if shaming
any explanation points maybe she's just
asking the question I don't know I don't
know but I just think it adds a little
spice people are too serious on Twitter
I just like people to know
I use explanation points to explain my
points okay I guess
so
she says no one said the woman 16 years
old in some cases allegedly and this
idea that 16 year olds like okay I know
we have the age of consent laws but this
idea that at 16 you are
if a man robs a bank at 16 is he
responsible why are women not
responsible for doing cam work just
because they're 16 what is the
difference between 16 and 18. I'm not
saying that men should go for 16 year
olds or whatever but my point is it's
still alleged you're still responsible
for it even if you're 16 because you're
still going to have real life
consequences but yes Tate said he
convinced the women to do sex webcam
work for making them think he's really
in love with him that's manipulation big
words is not feminism a lot of big words
are feminism that's my point is it look
you have to look into it the last
hundred years they have changed the
definitions of a lot of these words that
you weaponize the word manipulation when
women make choices so Tate convinced the
women to do sex work or maybe the women
chose to do sex work because they were
in love it it this idea that we we're
somehow absolved of all responsibility
and now we are manipulated no no no no
no no no no they made a choice and I'm
not going to blame the guy for them
making a choice and this is the thing
it's like shaming why support Tate
um because he's a positive influence on
the world I I don't believe in
crucifying someone for doing one one bad
thing you know nobody's perfect I'm sure
if we looked into everybody's past
you'll find something but the the
conservatives want to find anything on
Tate so they can crucify him
um and no I've said it I don't support
the pimp it now now what are these these
women are just super like naive and
innocent and just they're so like
they're just such victims oh they're
just manipulated women do these look
like women
that are just so sad and manipulated
these are the women
that we're defending
these are the women that were
manipulated and coerced
these are the women that wouldn't have
done cam work anyway
and that's the other thing a lot of
chicks they they found sex work one way
or another
they would have I
I'm just done my mind issue is the
infant is treating women like they are
children
um we wanted to be equal so here we are
equality
be equal be an adult be responsible for
the choices that you make and stop
blaming the men so the next story Adam
Adam Adam
the man that called me me a misogynist
hating women again I have been crying
all week
I've been crying
just so sad and like what'll I do if
Adam thinks I'm a misogynist wow I'm
just sad
um but Andrew Tate went on Aiden Ross's
stream and they brought up adam22 and
Elena the plug and also a update is that
now Adam I don't really under understand
how like the porn search wet ratings go
but I guess I guess now they're at the
top of the porn search so I guess in the
porn world this is like a w this is like
a win a lot of people have now seen Lena
screw a man that's not her husband but
they they had questions about it so
let's bring up The Tick Tock clip I got
Andrew they did a video
um basically Adam
they're you know they've been married
for a while they have a beautiful family
um and uh basically one day uh they
decided to uh basically Adam said uh hey
hun you go ahead and get a BBC by this
guy so they had a big black uh [__]
insert her puss and uh
not in the video
and um that's true pretty much what
happened and uh
uh thoughts enter
well I think I mentioned this on one of
my previous podcasts I said that I
wouldn't personally do that bro but it's
not my personal preference but I want to
make something clear I I I'm really
careful about
what I say to people I don't want to
insult anybody that's not who I am as a
person if that's their personal decision
to make then they can make their own
personal decisions and do as they please
I'm not here to sit and say they
shouldn't do it all I can say is I
wouldn't personally do that that's not
something I would allow my woman to do
so perhaps I'm missing something maybe I
can maybe you can tell me why I'm I'm
wrong I'm not sure would you guys let
your wife do that yeah I think that he's
the most important piece of contacts
that is missing is the fact that we
already had been doing porn for I mean
maybe five six years or really since the
very beginning of our relationship and
you know she is 32. she is a mother
realistically she's not gonna be doing
this forever but we decided that it made
a lot of sense for her to you know seize
upon the moment the fact that she still
got her youth about her and slurp up a
black [__] for the [__] paper man he
liked it he liked watching the video
yeah I was kind of turned on but I'm not
gonna lie
do you think that you have an emotional
attachment to this man now or like you
literally wouldn't care what happened to
him let's say heaven forbid something I
don't know he got locked up and went to
jail or something like would you care or
would you literally you have zero
interest in him as an individual feel
for him as I would feel for like almost
anyone I'd ever met who went to jail but
like no offense Jason I see you as like
a male sex doll
like no no emotional attachment to him
whatsoever no this is where I have my
emotional attachment okay
I hope I hope she's telling the truth
but you see how she's kind of hesitating
a little bit
you know
I just I find it so hard to believe that
you could sleep with someone and get no
emotional attachment you must do have
you must have had to have slept with so
many people to get to that point because
every person I know that's like that
they've never they didn't start off that
way which which sex was better because
you haven't had it Adam's you and sorry
Jason was the first let me let me say
something
I find this very uncomfortable to talk
about there's not many things I find
uncomfortable but I just find this
uncomfortable to talk about and the
reason is it's not because I mean I'm an
adult I know what sex is of course I've
lived a very varied life I just feel
like
I don't know we have so many people
watching us
and we're just talking about dick and
vagina do you think this is
below
us I don't know we're all pretty
intelligent people we talk about the
Matrix and how they're trying to dumb us
all down and trying to control all of
our minds and this base Instinct talk I
find it very
uncomfortable I don't find I'm not
comfortable being on this stream if I
was sitting with a woman next to me the
last thing I would talk about is our
personal life I just don't think it's
the smart thing to do and I don't think
that it is I don't have any interest in
the personal sex life of any married
couple and I don't want to hear about it
and I don't want to talk about it and I
just find it very uncomfortable I'm
extremely uncomfortable in this
situation that's the truth and I'm not
saying that from a position of weakness
I'm saying it from a position of
strength I don't like talking about
these things I don't like talking about
women getting [__] I don't like
talking about what I do with women I
don't like talking about any of it I
think that what I do in the bedroom with
a woman who I care about should be to a
degree sacred and I think it should be
completely private absolutely and I
don't want to hear about anyone else
[__] I want to make something clear
to this I've never watched I don't watch
porn I've never bought and only fans
I've never paid for sex my relationship
with sex is involves love and I don't
think it should happen outside of love
and I think that's the way that sex
should operate and I think that when you
decide and once again I could be wrong
when you decide to keep sex exclusively
for love just something beautiful and
special about it and if you decide not
to do that then you keep chasing a new
high and you can have threesomes and
[__] a bunch of girls and I'm not saying
I haven't done it but eventually you're
constantly just chasing a new high and
you end up just doing something weird
now is this the same degenerate guy that
the Trad cons are talking about
is he promoting degeneracy is this he's
saying to pimp out women now look it you
can you could say maybe there's no
Redemption from doing the cam work but
a lot of the trout cons have checkered
pasts that they wanted to be redeemed
from
yet there is no Grace for Tate
even though he's not even promoting
sleeping with a bunch of women
he's saying to only have sex with the
women you love
but yeah
[Music]
It's Gonna Stay Together Forever
um I mean in life Adam she's on me again
maybe not but I'm not cheater anymore I
left that in the past
divorce don't you think people are going
to attribute it to this event
like I always think that we're gonna be
together forever I mean we didn't get
married a long time ago we just got
married but uh it is unfortunate that if
like in 10 years we break up because
like let's say he cheated on me
everyone's gonna blame it on the fact
that I [__] Jason in July of 2023. I
don't think anyone's gonna think about
anything else nobody's gonna be thinking
about the fact that we did this in 10
years which when you're in the middle of
the storm and everybody's freaking out
on you every day it's kind of easy to
feel like oh this is going to Define my
life going forward now that may be true
to some extent because this has been
such a thing but I don't really think
that it's that likely to follow us 10
years into the future I don't know my
hopes my hope is to be with Adam forever
that is what I want
it's interesting how you can like people
slip up in the language they use
my hope is to be with Adam forever
unless he cheats on me how could he
cheat on you if you bring him other
girls
like if he screw someone like you see
what I'm saying and you might it may not
be from this specific event but it
really shows the leadership and the
direction of the relationship that's the
problem
is that okay maybe you can screw the one
dude and now you're over it you're just
like I'm done this is the sex doll man
and I just you know and you're free to
do that but my whole thing is people
will blame it on this because you have
shown the nature of the kind of
relationship you have and the leadership
in this relationship is either weak or
woman-led because she led the way in
that decision you know I wish you guys
well I hope you stay together but would
I bet on it
and I think it really
degrades the sanctity of marriage when
we have people getting married that say
well I hope I'm with them forever when
they haven't even been married a year
our last story today is Meghan Markle
and Harry now again this shows what
happens when we have a female-led
relationship
um for those of you that don't know
Meghan Markle basically convinced Harry
to leave royalty can you imagine like
I think I'm like sometimes these women
should give classes because like it's
like some chicks can't even get their
guy to like help with the dishes this
woman got her guy to leave his family
now obviously that's that's a terrible
thing we don't want that but I was just
thinking I'm like this girl
like how the hell what did she do to
like deserve this anyways
like she's cute but
she's not like you know she's cute but
it's not like
you know anyways anyways essentially she
convinced Harry to leave the royal
family she cried about the racism and
the sexism and blah blah blah and now
there are rumors that there's a new
report and this is all a legend that
Prince Harry and Meghan Markle are
taking time apart from the marriage
according to a radar online report
Prince Harry and Meghan Markle are
currently taking time apart to rebuild
their relationship after family drama
caused a rift in their relationship a
source close to the couple told the
Tabloid that personal as well well as
cultural differences have caused the
couple to drift apart Harry doesn't fit
in in Megan's Tacky Tinsel Tinseltown
World told the source
Prince Harry is reportedly planning a
solo trip to Africa to film a
documentary The anticipated solo trip
may just may be just what Harry needs as
he considers the continent his second
home and a place where he feels the most
like himself revealed the anonymous
source Markle on the other hand has
hired a new agent to help her build her
brand Royal expert Daniela alster told
the portal that Meghan Markle was
looking to establish her own brand and
make millions for the first time they
are truly on Divergent professional
paths she was quoted as saying to their
Radar Online the couple's real
the couple's relations the couple's
relationship reportedly worsened
worsened after their 20 million dollar
deal with Spotify failed to take off
moreover some financial troubles also
played spoilsport in their relationship
that stressed that stress coupled with
their emotional issues has made their
life a living hell taking time apart on
different continents will hopefully help
them find whatever they need to move on
claim the source the couples deal with
the popular streaming service came to an
end in all talks of a second season of
their podcast archetypes fell through
Harry's proposal to interview Donald
Trump Vladimir Putin Pope Francis and
Mark Zuckerberg puzzled the executive
Executives of Spotify at Spotify as per
reports yeah I mean no none of these
guys are going to interview a guy that's
led by his wife you don't even imagine
Trump's like yes I want to be
interviewed by a female-led house like
come on all right another anonymous
source told the celebrity gossip site
that the air had sold their lavish home
and
Monte Sido California and Harry was
staying elsewhere Harry and Megan got
married in a lavish wedding at St
George's Chapel in Windsor in May 19
2018. this is the thing when women lead
relationships when it's happy wife happy
life we lead you right to destruction
now I don't say this as a woman like I'm
happy about it okay you know when we say
give a hundred percent control and
authority to a man it's not like we're
like Yay but when you look at the
results of all of these couples where
the man follows the wife Adam and Lena
um Will Smith and Jada
now Prince Harry and Megan what are the
results of this women will always try to
expert control over men it is in our
nature it started with Adam and Eve and
if we allow that to take over us we
become bitter resentful and we ruin our
homes
it is something as women we need to
fight against
and the thing is the thing is
you left royalty this woman got him to
leave Roy like can you imagine
your life is paid for now there's
financial troubles what's going on
the marriage is gonna end I really hope
that he like goes back maybe I don't
know I don't know if they'll let him
back but it's like you feel so sad for
him because now as if his wife leaves
he's literally alone he's got nothing so
I I don't even what would you do as the
royal family he's been calling you guys
all racist like I
I don't even know what I would do in
that situation
let me know what you guys think thank
you for tuning in to another episode of
pearl daily
Maybe I'm Wrong maybe I'm crazy maybe I
just see feminism on the conservative
side because I live in la la land and I
don't know anything and I'm just a
provocateur who just wants to make
everybody mad you know maybe I'm just oh
just so crazy
and just not not you know Christian
enough that's what they'll say so let me
know in the comments like the video on
your way out subscribe to the channel
ring that notification Bell and I'll
talk to you next time